talks about yeah you know the female
genital mutilations female genital
mutilation yeah he talked to ayan Hirsi
Ali about it and she gets labeled in
Islamophobe because she talks openly
about the problems with the ideology
ayaan Hirsi Ali you do not speak for us
you did not speak for us you don't speak
for us you are not our ally you're not
interested in our lives or our freedom
you've described with some women as
being irrational
those are having no minds of our own
you've called us slaves how can you
claim to stand for our liberation when
you simply repeat the language of our
oppressors this is not the language of
solidarity or understanding or freedom
this is the language of patriarchy and
misogyny this is a language of white
supremacy this is the language used to
justify wars invasion and genocide
you're not here to help us or stand with
us you're here to profit from an
industry that exists to dehumanize us an
industry built on selling hatred
misinformation and stereotypes it's a
lucrative career appearing on panels TV
shows big-budget events where people
have to pay big money to hear you tick
you know where your audience wants and
you give it to them
despite globally recognized institutions
describing you as an extremist despite
your claims being developed over and
over again by academics and experts all
around the world despite your closest
associates being white nationalists and
far-right politicians it seems that
people never get tired of touring you to
repeat the same rhetoric over and over
again because there is nothing quite as
satisfying to colonizer than a subject
who becomes the salesperson for their
ideology we're not here to say that
Muslims are perfect no-one is but your
narrative doesn't support our struggles
it erases them like all women we resist
patriarchy and misogyny every day like
our mothers and grandmothers before us
we strive for dignity and equality
within our cultures and outside of them
but you don't
your livelihood depends on pretending
our histories don't exist that were
simply faceless nameless victims too
stupid to escape our savage traditions
you collapse our plurality into a single
convenient stereotype this is not
intellectual it's lazy this hatred you
feed puts us in danger every day it
encourages fear persecution and violence
this is not brave this is not
progressive this is propaganda bravery
is not selling lies bravery is living
through the relentless hostility
discrimination and pressure of a world
that fears us a world that you helped to
create and now she's here writing books
and giving lectures FGM FGM female
genital mutilation
so it's idea of female genital
mutilation most people have probably
heard about this it's cutting part of
the woman's private parts out or the
entire thing or closing it or something
like that
basically this practice began either in
Sudan or Egypt 800 BCE 800 years before
the birth of Jesus right what does that
say off the bat this is not something
that Islam introduced it's not something
that you know all of a sudden Islam
which came 600 years about 600 years
after Jesus or the Quran somehow
introduced into this region now where is
this taking place primarily it takes
place in Africa North East Africa and
kind of spread across Africa this is an
African issue so Christians are doing it
there Christians are doing it there let
me give you some statistics here you got
Eritrea Christian country majority
Christian you got Ethiopia Christian
country majority you know Christian
population and the rates of FGM in these
countries are 90 percent and 75 percent
means that Christians are doing it you
look at the country of Niger Niger is an
interesting case 55% of Christians in
Niger are practicing FGM 2% of Muslims
are practicing FGM
so what's going on here the Christians
are doing and the Muslims are not doing
it so what happened all of a sudden
something flipped around you look in
Eritrea
you're looking at level three FGM which
is infibulation which is the worst type
right it's tribal one tribe will do it
and the other tribe will not do it you
say well why is one tribe doing it
because it's a cultural thing all right
all the evidence indicates that this is
a cultural thing right that yeah some
Muslims do some Animists are doing it
people who are like you know have other
type of religions Christians are doing
it as well Coptic Christians in Egypt
are doing it as well right so this is an
African issue primarily a few other
countries like Yemen Indonesia because
you know it has to do with demographics
of how people moved into different
regions and travel this is not an
Islamic thing this is not an Islamic
problem it's not an Islamic issue did
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
did he have it done to his daughters
know where his own wives had this
procedure done no there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever so what it looks
like is that basically you know what
probably happened is that this was a
cultural practice and the Muslims in
that area were probably trying to use
their religion to justify that practice
even though it's not a very strong
justification the Christians did exactly
the same thing they were had this
practice as well and they tried to
justify it and what's really interesting
is when Christian missionaries arrived
in Africa and people were X n Turing
into Christianity the Christian Church
many of these Christian missionaries
they said you guys got to stop this
practice you guys stop doing it and they
wouldn't stop so they said okay we're
gonna kick you out we're gonna
excommunicate you from our churches you
can't even be a Christian anymore if you
continue this practice and they continue
to anyways and they said okay fine so
many people are kicked out of the church
which means that this is a tribal thing
our Muslims in Pakistan doing this no
our Muslims in Saudi Arabia are Muslims
in Syria are Muslims and Lebanon Muslim
and Palestine Muslims all across the
world like I said there's there's 49
majority Muslim countries one-third of
the Muslim population lives in other
places as minorities most the vast
majority of Muslims are not doing it you
don't have any solid evidence linking
this to you know it to being a practice
in Islam yet it keeps on being tied
somehow with the religion of Islam and I
don't understand why why this keeps
happening
looks like people whatever they can get
their hands on either out of context to
twist it to cherry-pick yeah any stone
they can get to throw I said it's it
just goes back to being and disingenuous
and misinformed and a victim many people
to that false propaganda die self but
yeah but Joe our friend Joel talks about
he talks about being professionally
objective supposed to be professionally
objective professionally wise and wise
right yeah one of those things is you
know to do what we're suggesting that he
does is why not have bring on your
friend mm-hmm
bring on someone like you and let's go
let's talk let's have it that'd be a
great think that would that would really
bring on a lot of lot of viewership huh
so a lot of people be in tune like now
he's got his his buddy who's making
these claims you know the mean and now
we got someone who's gonna fact-check it
right there and say yeah you have to go
back to the internet on the spot so
you're on right yeah yeah all right
let's go to to another one